[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
as an author of 17 books a former
professor of economics history English
and communications at the University of
Illinois at Chicago and a historian and
economist in her own right Deirdre
McCloskey welcome to the Rubin report no
thank you I'm very glad to be here that
is quite a bio for you it took it took
me a while to because there was a lot
that I had to leave out but there's only
so many words I can say in a sentence
I'm very old so I've had a very
complicated life so I I'm also an
adjunct professor of classics and
philosophy or was and I've taught
philosophy for money and in Holland and
so I I feel that you can't be a real
economist which is what my original
training was without at least reading
books and the other fields to kind of
put the rationality of humans in some
sort of context so you include the other
things they do yeah all right so before
we get going here I thought the best way
to start would be to read a quote from
you I've never done this or in the year
plus that I've been doing this show but
I thought this was so perfect and it
sort of captures everything about you
and I think you know what I'm gonna read
already I want to get this right
quote I'm a literary quantitative
postmodern free-market progressive
Episcopalian Midwestern woman from
Boston who was once a man not
conservative I'm a Christian libertarian
that's me that's me all the way I mean
you've given me everything I don't even
know where to go from here okay so where
should we go from here all right well
let's start because I don't think we
have to spend a tremendous amount of
time on it unless you want to but let's
just start with it with the trans stuff
well sure I was I was born Donald
by the way an Irish means world ruler so
you couldn't apply this to our president
oh lordy we'll get to him and then I
from age 11 on I'd wanted to be a woman
but I was born in 1942 so I'm very agent
and in 1953 there's nothing to be done
about it so I said okay I gotta be a guy
so so you're looking at the captain of
her high school football team Wow
admittedly a very small school I was in
college and was was married for 30 years
to the love of my life and have a couple
of grown children and three
grandchildren so I had a full male life
up to age 53 and then I my joke is did I
want to be an old man or an old woman
I thought oh well let's be an old woman
and it's not as trivial you know this
isn't about cost and benefit it's not a
career move to become a female professor
it doesn't improve your yeah the idea
that even you even frame that within an
economic model I did at one point I did
about two months so before I realized
that I could do it and should do it
which was August of 1995 I actually did
a cost-benefit study of changing gender
Wow I mean this is insane that's not how
you make decisions yes so what did you
do I mean you sat down and two columns
was completely ridiculous and then in
the middle of August 95 as the English
say they've got a nice expression I
twigged
to it I got it but I could do it and I
was not a sad sack before I was not
going to commit suicide or something but
I'm happier unfortunately my marriage
family turned against me my former wife
would of 30 years and my and my children
haven't spoken to me since those days
well did your wife know when you first
got married or throughout the marriage
yeah throughout the marriage she knew
what I knew which was that I was a
heterosexual crossdresser yeah every
once in a while not very often I
wouldn't dress in women's clothes not in
her presence and it wasn't a big deal
we'd like you know foot fetish or
something see guys as women learn have a
lot of little weirdnesses they go in for
and it doesn't really amount to anything
often and that's all I can view tit for
for decades I was terribly ashamed when
I was younger and then finally my 40s or
something you said ah well okay so what
so we went along perfectly well Minh
them that last year 1995 I I finally
twigged as I said so when you did it at
that age I mean people think of it now
you know transits become sort of hot now
right it wasn't at that time there was
really sort of nobody to you know I'm
sure you could find somebody
academically to look at not too many if
you did some research you could find
somebody but are you but very few in
terms of look you know culturally you
know and on television all that kinda
stuff so when you decided to do I mean
what was the reaction after you you had
a car you were professional it was there
it was kind of funny because the
economists tended to you know they're
all economists even if they're not
free-market economists tend to I think
the choice is desirable and we should
there's no controversy about it so
that's oh well it's no it's okay if he I
mean she wants to do it I mean where is
my history that would be the libertarian
that that's libertarian view but but
most economists even if they weren't
libertarian see seem to have this
attitude and then my historian
colleagues and my colleagues and
anthropology and so they they were less
is less easy for them to really because
they think in terms of identities and
they think and we once you have an
identity you're supposed to keep it if
you're Chicano you're Chicano period
right and it's I think that was their
problem but it wasn't you know I didn't
very few people turned away from me and
the women especially of all descriptions
were wonderful yeah in my book called
crossing a memoir published in 1999 I
have a
opening section where I thank all the
women who helped me a bit you know and
sending a nice letter or inviting me for
lunch and so on and it was 240 names one
of the three years of my transition well
what's the part of being trans that
people don't think about don't get us
it's not true the kind of journalistic
phrase a woman trapped in a man's body
or vice versa it turns out they're about
equal numbers on the other side going
the other way so they they think it's
this terrible conflict whereas you know
people adjust people adjusted to
extermination camps mm-hmm they can
adjust almost anything and I don't need
to compare being a guide to be an
extermination camp but but they can
adjust and and then the other thing they
need to know is that it's a minority
interest it's more common than we once
thought but it's not gonna change the
gender what it costs about as much as a
new car kind of a moderate new car not a
Mercedes and when I see new cars on the
street I say oh those people change oh
yeah they don't want it
most people are satisfied yeah and even
if they regard how men are treated or
women are treated as makes them uneasy
and they worry about gender stereotypes
nonetheless they're their comfort they
don't want to change yeah did you have
any regret after I know there's there's
something that's really important for
straight people to understand
no one has regretted a the number of
people who have a regret one way or the
other male to female female to male is
miniscule and be if they have regret
they can change back
it's okay well gee you can't grow a
penis
well so what many perfectly well
functioning men don't have penises from
terrible acts
answer war injuries big deal mm-hmm it's
how you present yourself it's how you
live in the world that's what determines
how society takes you on you know so I'm
curious you mentioned the economists
that you worked with and the historians
sociologists what about the
psychologists oh the psychologists are
fine but even back then were none of
them were not a problem but the
psychiatrists are really dangerous
yeah can you explain the different for
someone that doesn't know a difference
between a psychiatrist is one with an MD
yeah he's a doctor
there usually he but so she's anyway
he's a doctor then specializes in
diseases of mental diseases I don't
thank God there lots of things we can do
about depression and a little bit about
schizophrenia and the drugs and so on
they've been developed and I'm all for
it but the trouble is the psychiatrist
now these md's know nothing about
transgender things yet they figure
they're an expert you know the old joke
is what's the difference between God and
an MD God doesn't think he's an MD so I
was seized by my sister twice she tried
it three times for mental observation
and confined in a madhouse twice
Wow it cost me eight thousand dollars in
attorneys fees to get out of these
places this is when you were transiting
95 95 and that's the psychiatrist were
just really creepy it was the worst
horror movie you can think of well
Herrera's my advice to anyone who gets
seized for having the cops come seized
for observation don't make any jokes
there they have no sense of humor you
make a joke they write it they write it
down that's right you know I never
really thought of this before but so for
a psychiatrist in a weird way that they
would be the least qualified to deal
with a trans person because they're
because their method is based in drugs
right it's been drugs and it's
based in extreme pathologies mm-hmm oh
my god I mean I'm not against psychiatry
yeah the profession I think it's fine
although by the way it's the source of
homophobia the a hundred years of
homophobia in northern Europe was I
think closely connected with the rise of
Psychiatry as a profession but in any
case not against them in general but
they they they deal with people who are
really ill and so they want to put you
in some illness category mm-hmm
instead of saying oh well that's kind of
weird oh hey how about them Hawks that's
the more that's actually how the
students at the University of Iowa where
I was teaching at the time that's how
they react they had seen rock musicians
with eye makeup and Boy George and Sony
they didn't care no it didn't bother
them you know it's funny I only went to
a psychiatrist once yes I wanted to get
xanax because I used to have anxiety
related oh yeah just to fly should I was
on a plane and that was it that was the
only reason I wanted the psychiatrist
would not let me leave without telling
me that I had time shift disorders yeah
you [ __ ] sounds like an absurdly
made-up thing and gave me a prescription
for something else which I proceeded to
throw out when I walked out of the
building but that sort of idea we can
prescribe everything here here's there's
the symbol of it the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual of Mental Disorders
DSM it's been through five editions
since I think the 1960s that's got a
name and tell you how to diagnose all
the mental disorders it starts in the
1960s being about that thick about half
an inch thick by now it's about three
inches thick which implies that we've
all become crazy well what is that
weighs what does that that does that say
that our modern lives have made us
crazier or that the the pathology of
finding things wrong with people's the
authoritarian mentality mmm-hmm it's the
I'm from the government and I'm here to
take em I'm here to help you mentality
it's it's the nudge mentality it's the
Socialists mentality it's the
conservative mentality it's everything
except true liberalism which is if
people are not doing
to hurt you leave him alone yeah and so
that there's a deep libertarian argument
here the famous psychiatrist Thomas
Shaw's using my case in his last book as
an instance of the overreaching of the
profession of psychiatry look you get
put in a mental hospital you may not
ever get out because they're in charge
if you're put in jail for armed robbery
you pretty much know your chances of
getting out and so on because it's on TV
in the movie some conception if you know
from your friends but you don't know
with psychiatry it's very scary so I was
very frightened by this episode as my
sister was a psychologist academic
psychologist and at the time she was at
the Harvard School of Public Health so
you know she you can be sure that when
she wrote to the judges she used the
Harvard stationary yeah which I assume
helped at some level boy did it yeah and
she could say you know she told lies now
she and I are very close
but it took a few years for me to get
over it
yeah all right so one more thing on on
trans and then I want to move I want to
move to actual issues not to diminish
the trans issue but as we've established
it unfortunately it's going to be at
least the second sentence of my obituary
I'm trying to drive it I don't know the
fourth Center yeah well look you gave me
a lot of good other buzzwords here so
we're gonna get to those in just a
second
my last thought it would be 2016 I mean
this was the year that trans really
became oh yes you know from from caitlyn
jenner
to orange is the new black and joy this
feeling of there are you know trans
actors now there's a visibility Trant a
transparent yet transparent of course
we're the only sane person on the set is
the transition yeah yeah exactly
really flipping everything on its head
that must feel incredibly validating for
you well it wouldn't isn't so much
validating man I had a lot of years to
work on validation but it but it it's
another freedom look all men are created
equal endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights a slave owner
wrote that yet it's been the kind of
marker laying down a marker for American
politics and we keep pushing it first we
got rid of slavery eventually and then
then we had votes for women then we had
finally
civil rights in the south then we had
rights for then we had feminism and we
had gay rights then we had handicapped
rights and all the ones that happened
during my lifetime I have the correct
opinions about I was in favor of the
civil rights movement I wasn't against
Vietnam I was in favor of gay rights as
in favor of women's rights bababa but I
didn't do anything about it I didn't
burn my draft card I was still Donald I
didn't do you know I just said oh gee
that's good well then God in 1995 tapped
me on the shoulder and if she said she's
me my anglican god she said okay dearie
now you can you can testify if you don't
do this if you don't I mean allow
yourself to be a public exponent for
trans people and then you're just a jerk
and so I did and so I've been been
giving talks I'm not a professional
gender cross huh I'm a scholar I'm a
teacher I'm a writer
yeah but I think I should a tenured
professor should be the one who stands
up because she can't be fired yeah
that's a little bit it reminds me sort
of of when Jason Collins the NBA
basketball player yeah yeah he was
really sort of at the end of his
career wasn't so it allowed him to do it
in a way that where they knew the Nets
could sign him and then at the same time
he wasn't gonna play much you would sort
of go under the radar but yeah but
something good would have come out of it
but you put a little oh you took risks
obviously you know you you put your butt
on well I thought I was gonna lose my
job but actually turns out that the
University of Iowa where I was teaching
at the time was very progressive in
these matters wait way way more
progressive than my alma mater which is
Harvard mm-hmm in the 90s Harvard you
know the eastern privates took a long
time to get on this particular train but
it didn't happen but I but it shows in
such a career driven person as me such a
person who wants to publish books and so
on
it shows how much I wanted it when I
when I realized I could do it that I was
willing to lose my job
[Music]
you